Marylyn starts off this hour in Raleigh
North Carolina hi Marilyn welcome to the
Dave Ramsey show hi Dave how are you
better than I deserve what's up hey just
started following it I'm interested in
starting the baby steps i I don't know
what I should start or where to start my
husband is currently military and I'm a
stay-at-home mom
models are smart to start the baby steps
now because I'm not working okay well I
mean there's nothing keeping you from
stopping them what the baby steps is for
is just what to do first what to do
second when I can find some money and we
generally find money by getting on a
budget making the dollars that we have
behave sometimes we find money by
selling things sometimes we find money
by taking more jobs but you know
basically when I get some money what am
I going to do with it and the first
thing you're gonna do before you even
worry about that is get yourself on a
written gameplan and then when you can
squeeze dollars out of your existing
budget what am I gonna do with them well
that's the baby steps are you behind on
anything no not behind or anything I
think we're in a pretty good place I
kind of got us in a place where there
were only about 20,000 years old cars
900 and credit cards
we have about 2,500 dollars coming in
monthly with ship pay and 1,600 rolling
out so do you have his income is thirty
thousand dollars a year and you have
twenty thousand dollars on your cars no
he's he's bringing in about 40 and
that's after-tax okay that'd be more
than 2,300 unless you're getting a huge
tax refund yeah we get about easily
about eleven eleven thousand dollars
yeah okay well that's one thing we've
got to change immediately because a tax
refund is like buying a shirt at the
store and you take it back and they give
you money back that was your money
the reason you got $11,000 is because
you gave the government throughout the
year $11,000 too much out of his check
so you need to change his withholding
immediately okay and start bringing home
an extra what eight hundred nine hundred
dollars a month okay because that's and
that's going to help a bunch all right
that's good now is housing furnished own
base that's furnished housing ok and
what about food
yes food we do a little the two hundred
a month for food yeah so his food is
furnished but then are you have children
yeah we have three kids I mean it's only
deployed so he's getting a little extra
money in now so I want to know the best
way of house is handled that extra money
that blown it okay the first thing we're
going to do is which is the most
expensive car we have a 2015 equinox
which is only costing us 460 a month
yeah that needs to go together
yeah that car all together you can't
afford that car yeah it's killing you
yeah the police only got a tradition
last year which I just believe financed
it last weekend got it down to 131 $60 a
month payment oh there we go
yeah the equinox needs to go bye-bye
yeah here's the thing okay you cannot
build wealth when you have cars that
total up more than half your annual
income and you do and you do the little
girl Dennis out of you knows I'm thinks
I'm wrong but the woman who's the woman
who's a grown up knows I'm right right
you know as a grownup that I'm right
there's just not what you want to do
it's like you know don't take my gummy
bears away right but yeah you got it you
got to get rid of that stupid thing so
hey so I'm gonna adjust you're
withholding
get rid of the equinox and we're gonna
get another car for five or six thousand
dollars we pay cash for soon or we pay
it off really soon would that reduce we
got three we have wonderful good well
that makes it really easy to sell it
this four hundred sixty dollars a month
you got a lot of money to do a little
work yeah we got a little bit the plain
lip here I'm kind of trying to figure
out which way to go then work your way
right up those baby steps and you'll be
fine all right yeah I think I think hey
listen here's the thing we have a system
a class called Financial Peace
University it's nine weeks long and you
go the class at a local church in your
area but it's also online and it comes
with a one-year membership for the whole
online thing and that includes the every
dollar budgeting app tied to your bank
called every dollar plus it's all
included it's about six hundred dollars
worth of stuff I'm gonna give it to you
free but here's the way you're going to
use it okay
you're gonna start going to class and
he's gonna watch the same video you're
watching while he's deployed and he can
look at the every dollar app and track
with the budgeting and you guys can
communicate and make these decisions
together while he's deployed because all
of this is online as well okay now if I
give it to you will you use it and get
your life straightened out I absolutely
will all right hey we appreciate your
service the country kiddo
hold on Kelly's gonna pick up and we'll
get you guys in the class